muy buenos días si la fecha que se
conmemora es el 15 de enero
datos sobre molière bueno un poco sobre
su infancia como
el nacimiento en un barrio muy popular
en parís en aquella época como era real
e influyó muchísimo en en su obra
posteriores morán en obras de teatro
moliere fue un fino observador desde muy
temprana edad y
cambió la manera de hacer de la
distancia el se rodeó de personas que le
ayudaron en esta búsqueda de hacer un
teatro diferente y se inspiró en su
infancia de los humoristas que
representaban un pequeño sketch en la
calle muy cerca de donde él vivía es
solo lo motivó a seguir la carrera de
teatro además fue un hombre polifacético
porque no solamente fue dramaturgo
también produjo sus obras crea una
compañía de teatro era un actor
brillante
entonces era un hombre muy completo que
revolución el teatro en francia en el
siglo 17 y que se abrió paso en
versalles como era la dualidad entre
entretener al rey sol en el palacio
versus las prohibiciones de la iglesia
católica claro por supuesto tuvo su obra
tartufo que fue creo yo la obra que más
espinas levantó en la iglesia su obra
tuvo que cambiar varias veces para
[Música]
hacerle un poco el
quite a la prohibición eclesiástica él
tuvo la gran ventaja de ser el protegido
de del rey de louis 14 entonces esto le
permitió hacer muchas cosas que para
otras personas en su época no era
permitido el rey le perdonó y le
aceptaba muchas de las críticas porque
bueno molida en sus obras se retrataba
mucho la sociedad como dije antes era
era un hombre que observaba mucho lo que
pasaba a su alrededor y se inspiraba de
lo que sucedía para escribir sus citas y
muchas veces en esas obras habrían había
es muy mordaz es entonces él tuvo la
gran fortuna de que el rey sol de que
vista por se aceptara aceptara porque
bueno le parece un hombre brillante era
un de talentoso y él aceptó y lo
protegió hasta el final y esa fue la
gran fortuna también para que él ya
pudiera desarrollar una carrera tan rica
tan brillante en francia- y seguramente
para que lo recordemos hoy muy
rápidamente donde se acercan las
elecciones de francia y varios políticos
hablan del posible paso del dramaturgo
al panteón nacional usted qué opina
yo creo que es un nombre importante el
teatro francés es conocido los grandes
clásicos franceses bueno molière es la
punta de lanza y creo que es conocido a
nivel mundial y pienso que es lo más
lógico y lo más justo de que él esté
dentro de los grandes en el gente con
distancia no sé es mi opinión personal
pienso que él ha hecho muchísimo por
francia su obra es tan atemporal que
incluso ve cuatrocientos años después
seguimos hablando del impacto que sigue
teniendo porque tanto su obra como él
como personaje ha inspirado a muchísimos
a lo largo de la historia y muchos han
escrito obras basadas en el personaje